bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs émission spéciale dinara c'est
la grosse actualité en ce moment avec
évidemment garry kasparov et anatoli
karpov judit polgar aleksander grad
chouk shirov et peter l'écho nous avons
sur le plateau un invité spécial qui va
nous parler d'une rsa il s'agit du
maître international français jean-luc
chavanon vice-champion de france 93
bonsoir jean luc bonsoir et loire alors
en forme oui tout à fait en pleine forme
linarès qu'est-ce que ça t'évoque
malines rsc le ton à l'ennemi tic des
échecs donc qui existe depuis plusieurs
années déjà et est à chaque fois donc
des confrontations entre kasparov et
karpov
il ya une dizaine d'années et là le
grand retour de d'anatolie karpov au top
niveau grand retour d'un deuil karpov
alors je sais pas si on peut parler de
retour quand même puisque c'est un
tournoi qu'il joue comme ça au passage
rappelons qu'elle notable karpov a quand
même été champion du monde pendant dix
ans consécutifs
ça fait 17 ans maintenant qu'il n'est
plus champion du monde
là il joue un tournoi il est à garry
kasparov et donc pour l'instant ça se
passe pas très bien pour le jeune
j'allais dire un atelier karpov
non ça se passe pas très bien il vient
de perdre une partie contre contre
garrigues et une partie une partie
catastrophique et donc où gary a
vraiment été royal
gary impérial effectivement ça arrive
quand même assez régulièrement on
s'était quittés sur à la fin de la
deuxième ronde où on ne savait pas le
résultat de la partie
karpov shirov enfin chez rough avec du
blanc c'était un parti commenté l était
pas terminée au direct de la semaine
dernière donc finalement la partie s'est
achevée par la nulle un match nul donc
pour cette partie ensuite il ya eu donc
dans les trois premières rondes 9 nuls
consécutive
on rappelle que linares et d'un tournoi
double ronde avec six joueurs ce qui
fait donc dix parties en tout sur les
trois premières parties il ya eu donc
neuf matches neuf matches nuls alors des
matches annulés linares à col d'agnes
l'ensemble oui c'est très curieux mais
c'étaient des parties très combative il
se trouve que bon les joueurs en début
de tournoi sont très bien préparés ils
ont beaucoup d'énergie et donc forcément
ils se défendent mieux mais après
quelques rondes
la situation a changé ça a changé
garry kasparov a commencé à mettre le
turbo puisque le garry kasparov
quand même et favori de ce tournoi donc
quand il commence avec trois parties
nulles c'est pas un bon score pour lui
il avec turbo il a encaissé trois gains
consécutifs
pas mal oui il est en train de faire un
petit peu comme il l'avait fait il ya un
mois à wisches kanz et il met le turbo
il met le turbo et il enchaîne bien sûr
rien là il était dans une situation
correcte on va dire qu'il personnes
étaient devant lui mais
mais il n'empêche que qui il est très
impressionnant dans sa manière
d'enchaîner les points on va commenter
tout de suite le classement actuel du
tournoi donc on a joué six rondes pour
le moment premier garry kasparov donc
avec quatre ans et demi sur six
effectivement on l'a dit c'est il a mis
le turbo il est impérial il domine
complètement le tendre deuxième du
tournoi un point derrière il s'agit
quand même d'une petite surprise puisque
ce n'est pas un homme c'est une femme
il s'agit de judit polgar alors jean-luc
un petit commentaire
et bien judith prépare son grand retour
je crois que judith a été très déçu de
ne pas avoir joué le championnat du
monde
le championnat du monde fidjeu près du
monde fis des qui avait lieu fin d'année
new delhi était oui et donc c'est
beaucoup préparé probablement elle a
fait elle enchaîné bons résultats sur
bons résultats ces dernières ces
derniers mois et là elle et elle est
prête pour ce tournoi elle suffisamment
d'expérience et tout est et elle a envie
de
revenir au top niveau on va rappeler
donc que judit polgar est une exception
puisque c'est la meilleure femme de tous
les temps de très très loin puisque
c'est la seule qui a réussi à se classer
dans les 20 meilleurs joueurs du monde
alors que évidemment les suivantes ne
sont pas dans les 100 meilleurs ou alors
très péniblement
donc j'ai dit aux gars exceptionnel elle
est très en forme donc la deuxième place
pour l'instant linares très belle
performance en 3e place nous retrouvons
avec trois points alexei shirov donc 3
points 50%
oui donc alexei shirov qui qui qui fait
un tournoi normal on va dire mais qui
peut peut-être accrocher gary on
l'espère mais ça va être difficile
alors ça on commentera sur les rondes à
venir les rondes choc en fin d'émission
donc alexei shirov trois points pas
terrible pour le moment on pouvait
attendre mieux quand même
oui on peut attendre mieux d'alexei
shirov mais on doit dire que qu' il est
peut-être encore sous le coup de ce
qu'il a fait encore un bus can be où il
avait pris un départ canon et
il avait craqué peut-être qu'il n'a
encore affecté par cette fin de tournoi
à noter qui s'est repris puisqu'il a
perdu une partie contre judit polgar le
lendemain il a massacré raid choc donc
peut-être de bon augure pour avec ses
chiens of quatrième position nous avons
deux ex-aequo il s'agit d' anatoli
karpov et pita rico qui ont tous les
deux moins 1
c'est à dire qu'ils ont tous les deux
perdu contre kasparov effet nul contre
le reste alors donc deux analyses menées
sur les communes sur karpov malécot
comme d'habitude fait beaucoup de nuls
on espère qu'il va quand même gagné une
partie et tout mais mais bon il reste
néanmoins très très solide un jour très
très solide quant à noter et karpov
il est il est moins fort qu'avant ça
c'est fait clair et on espère pour lui
qu'il va qui va rester à peu près à ce
niveau là dans au classement général
mais alors donc pour l'instant tu penses
que c'est un bon résultat d'un hôtel et
karpov
je pense que pour l'instant la tôle et
karpov et fait un bon résultat en
faisant moins alors qu'on aurait pu
quand même attendre de la part d'un
actionnaire du monde des ressources
cachées voire même gagné le temps mais
comme tu l'as dit anatoli karpov été
champion du monde
il a perdu son titre il ya 17 ans et en
17 ans beaucoup de choses se sont
passées
il ya eu de l'eau sous les ponts ou les
pièges ya peut-être un joueur qui a un
petit peu plus que 19 ans qui à 19 ans
dans le tournoi
oui great choc entre deux shows calories
les derniers ont donc on y arrive il n'a
pas 19 ans il a 17 ans et ben voilà il
extrêmement jeune 17 ans donc c'est à
dire qu'il est né quand karpov garder
son titre face à kasparov alexander
gluck là il est dernier de ce tournoi il
a deux points sur six dont il a deux
défaites une contre
alexei shirov l'autre contre garry
kasparov bain en ce qui concerne les
séries shoot je pense que c'est un
excellent joueur c'est un joueur qui a
beaucoup de talent qui a fait quand même
demi-finaliste du championnat du monde
donc c'est quand même fantastique à 17
ans et on peut dire que peut-être son
manque de préparation à ce niveau fait
sa petite performance dans ce tournoi il
ne peut pas il peut pas toujours faire
d'excellents résultats mais mes jeux
quand même j'ai confiance je pense qu'il
est il peut il peut se ressaisir dans ce
tome on l'espère pour lui un trouble est
ce parce que c'est vrai que c'est un
début difficile
c'est son premier grand tournoi donc
avec saïda et chioukhs en difficulté
pour le moment on va tout de suite parti
passer jean luc à la partie commenter
puisque c'est comme le coeur de cette
émission
donc là nous avons choisi la partie
kasparov et karpov donc pour les
nostalgiques un oui donc pour les
nostalgiques une partie kasparov et
karpov
comme au bon vieux temps voilà donc donc
la partie commence avec le coût de 4 1
we could halal alors tout ça c'est très
joli mais pas très efficace il ya des
effets spéciaux voilà quatre garry
kasparov avec les blancs il commence
régulièrement avec ce coup mais il peut
il peut jouer tous les coups alors
jean-luc on sait que tu es un
spécialiste de la psychologie enfin ce
qu'ils ne savent pas vont le découvrir
dans cette édition
tu as une méthode pour analyser les
styles des joueurs se comprendre un peu
ce qu'ils font est et pourquoi il ajouté
l'ouverture quelles sont leurs types de
position préférée donc garry kasparov et
les blancs il peut jouer ce qu'il veut
et contre anatoli karpov il choisit le
cou aux quatre alors des explications
bon ben je crois que pour cette partie
comme ils ne rencontrent pas pas très
souvent karpov
il a préparé il a préparé e 4 parce
qu'il ya un jeu très très violent et
qu'actuellement karpov n'était plus apte
à défendre
il n'était pas aussi bien préparés
qu'auparavant donc il n'est pas capable
de défendre ce genre de coups en plus il
a toujours envie de marquer
de marquer un point psychologique
important en gagnant une partie
supplémentaire contre karpov coups
agressifs
garry kasparov est là pour gagner c'est
ce qu'il veut signifier enjoint le cou
aux quatre exactement et il dit au
passage à karpov mon vieux je vais te
voir tu sais plus calculer voilà il m'a
dit oui mais oui un petit peu un petit
peu donc alors tous ces commentaires
autour d'un premier coup ça paraît un
peu curieux mais enfin c'est important
puisque cette partie a évidemment un
passif énorme c'est la 172e rencontre
entre les deux champions donc il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire ne serait ce
que dans le choix de l'ouverture
puisqu'ils ont joué à peu près les
ventes tout l'éventail d'ouverture aux
échecs
donc voilà pourquoi tous ces
commentaires sur le simple coup de garry
kasparov e4 anatoli karpov lui joue ses
six oui puisque donc avec tous les cas
peuvent donc qui joue son répertoire il
joue actuellement et enfin il a toujours
joué deux coups ses 6 et 4 5
oui c'est ces deux couleurs 4,5 c'est la
symétrie voilà et c'est si c'est la cas
rocade il a toujours joué de varen très
très solide donc il reste fidèle à son
répertoire et donc donc voilà donc garé
savez probablement ce qui l'attendait et
il préférait jouer eux 4 à des cats où
il aurait dû affronter une défense nîmes
the beach qui est peut-être actuellement
plus plus résistantes
à noter quand même que la star made in a
recent voit énormément d'un âge d'or
alors la nage d'offres qu'est ce que
c'est c'est une sicilienne et pour ça ça
veut dire que pratiquement tous les
joueurs jouent au premier coup de 2,4
donc en ce moment il semblerait que des
cadres soit un peu moins de jouer au top
niveau que le cadre donc revient en
forme
du coup violent le pion du roi des cats
et un petit peu passé de mode
apparemment les dents en trouver des
solutions pour le sauf le champion du
monde l'admirent crown et kick ramener
qui jouent des cap des 4 maintenant au
deuxième coup des 5
c'est la position de base de la car au
delà il ya beaucoup de choix pour les
blancs enfin non enfin ira
principalement deux soit cassé 3 soit
aux 5
voilà voilà les deux choix qu'a laissé
trois peut-être est plus calme oui les
deux coups sont différentes en cavalier
c3 est plus calme parce que la position
souvent un petit peu au centre alors
qu'avec eux 5
les blancs ferme la position il laisse
au noir la possibilité comme on va le
voir de développer leur fout de ses 8
mai ils vont réagir très très
brutalement je pense qu'il faut
continuer la partie pour expliquer plus
clairement eu 5 c'est donc un coup
particulièrement agressif qui ferme le
centre dont qui permet aux noirs de
jouer se couche au f5 qui est tout
l'idée de la carro cannes en fait quand
on joue une carreaux cannes par
opposition à une française où on a joué
le coup de 7 6 pour venir contrôler le
centre plutôt que le crous et 6
c'est pour sortir notre fou s'est vite
donc ça c'est toute l'idée de l'acca
locale ici maintenant il ya encore un
choix pour les blancs jean-luc oui donc
cavalier c3 et c3 qui a été jouée par
kasparov donc la ligne la plus jouée ces
derniers temps ce je crois que c'était
cavaliers f3 oui c'était plutôt sale
coup effectivement donc quelques
cavaliers f3 toujours pour garder
éventuellement la possibilité de garder
une chaîne de pions compact alors c'est
à dire le pion ces deux possibilités de
le mettre en c3 où on sait 4 ou en c4
plus violents ou en c4 est dans cette
position jouant cavalier ces trois gars
y pense tout simplement à développer ces
pièces le plus vite possible
donc il montre des intentions agressives
à noter que une autre remarque un ce
camion c3 ne bloque pas la dame
donc ça rend possible coup j'ai dauger
quatre cellules des idées de jouer et
qu'elle et ses 3 à la place de cabaye
est roi anatoly karpov tout aussi ce là
on est dans la théorie cette vente a été
joué énormément par alexei shirov
d'ailleurs est ici garry kasparov joue
le coup violent qui est de la
justification au fait de quelle est
cette fois le coup j'ai dauger quatre
attaques le fou le foot doit donc se
retirer ranger 6 maintenant qu'elle est
chez pas en fait quel est l'enjeu de
cette position-là des prochains coups
avenir en or ce type dans ce type de
position
ben les blancs vont chercher
probablement à piquer le fou donc en
poussant h 2 h 4 et en préparant hhk
tâche 500 ferment ils font ce serait une
idée et de dons qui vont ils veulent
provoquer tout simplement un
affaiblissement de les droits dus
du roi noir et en plus comme de toute
façon les noirs les noirs dans cette
position doivent choisir un camp pour
roque et donc dans cette position en
leur laisse moins de moins de
possibilités on leur dit ok bon
maintenant développer vos ll dame pour
oak est votre droit mais s'ils se
développer à la maison ils ont beaucoup
de pièces qui sont très très mal
développé les droits c'est assez
compliqué donc donc le plan des blancs
pour résumer et peut être simplifié
c'est de jouer le pion h évitez
éventuellement que les noirs on arrive à
cacher leur fou en jouant le pion h
eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire donc garry
kasparov joue cavalier j'ai eu deux
l'idée c'est de mettre le cavalier en f4
ensuite donc ça met une pression sur ce
fou g6 et empêche les noirs de boucher
le puits au match puisqu'à ce moment on
prendra le fou et ensuite poussé le pion
h 2 h 4 h 5 voilà ça c'est le plan des
blancs maintenant la question qu'on se
pose au point noir c'est comment sortir
les pièces de la façon la plus efficace
possible est celle qui va nous permettre
justement ne pas nous faire enfermer
notre fou c'est le sait le débat ici
oui c'est le grand débat dans cette
position donc alors oui on parle
beaucoup de débats en ce moment toujours
à cause de la politique mais
effectivement sur des gonaïves ya un
vrai débat d'idées
as tu peur de ça parce qu'il ya bientôt
les élections c'est ça va être tout à
fait élections présidentielles au niveau
de la fédération française d'échecs
aussi au niveau municipal appareils
d'accord donc cavalier gp2 donc pour
prendre ce fou je crois que karpov dans
cette position habituellement joué f7 et
six f 16 f 6 alors ça c'est je ne
connais pas ce coup donc c'est ce coup
là je crois qu'ils jouaient ce coût est
sûre cavaliers qu'avait cavaliers f4
s'amène une position très compliqué on
rapatrie ou je ne sais pas je bous
lentillons propre en hausse avant
imposition
d'accord donc ça serait une variante
complexe là une variante complète une
vente complexe mais que probablement
garé à
on a énormément étudiés de toute façon
ça ne fait aucun doute quand on voit
cette position arrivait sur l'échiquier
que garry kasparov et très très bien
préparé dans cette ligne il n'a pas joué
ça par hasard
oui je crois qu'ils cherchent ils
cherchent la schl au cas où le quai foch
le carreau il veut tout simplement tuer
son adversaire
il n'est pas là pour rigoler anatoly
karpov donc trouve un plan de
développement qui est un plan qui existe
un bien sûr qui est pas mal cavaliers en
eaux cette
voilà pourquoi pas il fallait il faut
bien sortir ces pièces donc on met le
cas vanilla garry kasparov lui ça
n'empêche pas de poursuivre cavalière 4
toujours dans cette idée h 4 h 5
et là il faut réagir de façon centrale
donc c'est simple mais c'est simple le
coup naturel le cook que tout le monde
attendait dans cette position il faut il
faut casser cette structure surtout que
comme on l'a expliqué tout à l'heure la
chaîne de pions blanche n'est pas n'est
pas uni c'est à dire les pions des ktm 5
ne sont pas ne sont pas soutenues par
d'autres pions ce qui fait que l'on ne
peut pas jouer ses trois ans on peut pas
jouer ça veut dire à ce qui fait que
donc la chaîne de pions blanche se
retrouve fragilisée mais en échange de
cette fragilité
les blancs ont développé toutes leurs
pièces les blancs sorti pas mal de
pièces et en plus ya de fous g6 qui est
quand même
et en plus le sujet à certaines
pressions exactement
tu reprends ses 5 alors là on se demande
pourquoi on va prendre dans ces cinq
hommes c'est parce qu'on veut pas c'est
pour gagner du temps ou pour puisque
pourquoi pourquoi aller chercher ce pion
des français sont inquiets parce qu'il y
avait peut-être d'autres possibilités
non je pense que l'idée de gagner du
temps et intéressante il faut que les
noirs récupère le matériel est donc le
ton et le ton et la manière que vont
utiliser
les noirs pour récupérer ce matériel va
permettre aux blancs de se développer
encore encore plus d'accord parce que
positionnement on est bien d'accord que
c'est pas du tout justiciable de jouer
un coup comme dépensé 5 dans la mesure
où maintenant l'option c5 va bien
entendu être récupéré et l'option aux 5
est affaibli oui dans cette position
donc la positionnement c'est la vérité
du côté de karpov
on peut dire la vérité du côté de pâques
karpov mais kasparov s'appuie sur des
facteurs plutôt dynamique on veut dire
qu'avec 17 et karpov va ramasser les
pions h4 kasparov menace lui à son tour
de gagner une pièce puisque on voit que
après h5 le fou à claude cazes
il faut qu'il vienne sur la case de 4
c'est la seule et là on joue simplement
f3 donc on a trois pions comme ça qui
contrôle toutes les cases du fou et on
prend le fou donc on menace de gagner
une pièce avec ce couac
4la karpov s'en fout en fait louer
karpov récupère un pion et le cahier
propension aux 5 et là que se passe-t-il
l'idée donc sur h5 jean luc tu me
contredira peut-être c'est de mettre le
feu aux quatre oui quand je suis pas de
contredire puisque dans cette position
f3 n'est plus possible
voilà c'est ça le coup f2 f3 n'est pas
précis puisque et le fouet le cavalier
qui contrôle cette case f3 donc l'option
serait temps prise
donc on est obligé de prendre le fou 1,4
cette fois ci ce qui serait la pression
prendre on peut vraiment dire que les
noirs sont bien aux îles et noir ont une
très bonne position des positions ces
menaces cavaliers f3 il récupérer les
années 50 et râle caisse des cinq donc
là les pièces noires en fait peuvent se
déployer dans cette langue qu'on donne à
titre d'exemple et montre bien l'énergie
potentielle dans la position de karpov
qui peut se desserrer comme un ressort
en fait donc après qu'elle ait promis 5
h 5 n'est pas possible parce qu'il faut
aux quatre donc fou j'ai deux rouges et
deux pour contrôler le la case f3 hélas
hélas cadeau 4 oui donc pour menacer h5
fou 4-3 pour gagner la pièce réitération
de la menace h 5 x 4 pions f3 gifu
réaction karpov indispensable donc là il
faut pousser un petit pion à les droits
c'est ce que gary a provoqué a cherché à
provoquer depuis le début de cette
ouverture est
et il y arrive finalement donc est ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est une
capitulation de la part de karpov qui
joue le coup h5 il était obligé de le
faire donc
et chaque dans l'ouverture ont pas tout
à fait non pas tout à fait je pense que
bon dans cette position karpov doit doit
réagir de toute façon c'est une réaction
assez naturel
l'erreur qu'a dû faire karpov je pense
que se situe après je pense que c'est
pour la santé le jeu à peu près normal
h5 dames 2 un coût normal de
développement garry kasparov prépare le
grand aucun n'a évidemment et eric
l'inspirent off qui comme on peut le
constater donc dans cette position a
beaucoup plus de pions sur la deuxième
rangée allait l'allèle dames et donc il
va il va mettre son roi à l'abri du côté
le plus protégé du code est plus protégé
c'est logique
en plus la dame en e2 c'est une bonne
carte puisque elle garde un oeil quand
même éventuellement sur le roi noir ce
qui permettra des combinaisons
éventuellement sacrifice a aussi attaqué
le cavalier aux cinq déjà elle est ce
que le contrôle des risques elle
contrôle aussi la case des cinq donc une
case sur laquelle peut venir le cavalier
c3 qui pourrait éventuellement venir
titiller le roi le roi en 8 par des six
beaucoup de flèches on le verra puisque
c'est arrivé dans la partie c'est arrivé
près de chez vous donc kv7 ces six là il
prend g6 gary oued marié décide de
prendre la paire de fou on reprend du
cavalier puisque production ça serait
affreux on n'aurait plus aucun contrôle
des cases blanches ont une tenue ah oui
ce serait une catastrophe
catastrophe serait synonyme d'abandon à
ce niveau là rien au moins mais une
structure de pions complètement
déplorable donc les blancs se
régaleraient on prend des cavaliers fou
g5 voilà fou g5 pas mal donc l'idée
l'idée de cavaliers projet si c'est à
dire trouver une case parfaite pour ce 2
pour ce fou une case de développement
est parfaite donc on enlève le cavalier
de f4 et on met le fond g5 tout
simplement les cavaliers étaient là donc
maintenant qu'il n'y ait plus le fou
passe donc kasparov qui continue donc
qui continue le thème de cette ouverture
c'est à dire un thème extrêmement
dynamique
donc il développe ses pièces de manière
très violente très puissante et est en
voie en même temps que se forge un
contrôle cette diagonale h cap des 8es
donc une diagonale qui est proche du roi
8 qui pour l'instant n'a pas d'abri
c'est vrai c'est en fait c'est un coup
d'attaqués en même temps beaucoup d'
attaque il faut qu'on commence à prendre
le contrôle de cases clés autour de
renoir
il ya des solutions pour les noirs il ya
beaucoup de coups possibles un jean-luc
dans ses positions notamment évidemment
le coup qui a joué karpov s'est pas
vraiment une surprise isolé qui est tout
naturel encore une fois fuglseth avec
fawcett qui a donc plusieurs avantages 1
la dame n'est plus en prise puisqu'on
interposés une pièce entre le fou blanc
qui était angers 5 est la même des 8 et
en même temps on interposés une pièce
entre la dame blanche et le roi noir
c'est toujours ce fou hausse est donc on
va mettre un jaune qui bloque un peu
toutes les lignées diagonale qui permet
donc un jeu de défense solide pour
l'instant où karpov se défend
correctement pour l'instant alors
maintenant garry kasparov bouger pour h5
donc caspar dans cette fois ci en fait
on s'en fout de la structure de pions il
n'est pas là pour avoir une belle
structure d'options puisqu'on voit donc
des pions doublé un petit pion tout seul
encore des pions doublé donc structure
très mauvaise pour garry kasparov
mais par contre jeu très dynamique
puisque toutes les lignes sont ouvertes
donc dès que les taux vont arriver ça
risque de faire mal
anatoly karpov wii un jeu extrêmement
sauvage fulgurant et probablement un jeu
qui qui qui effraie anatoli karpov le
prix carpeaux fap le vieil anatole est
il atteint d'accord les ifi par par
faire une erreur
est-ce que kasparov la lutte dans son
regard je crois que
il a compris que un atelier n'était plus
tu es plus aussi aussi talentueux que
qu'avant donc c'est ici le moment clé
c'est pour ça que instant à ses solos
nan c'est la faute d'anatolie karpov
ici ils avaient des options pour tenir
et ils jouent la première l'imprécision
de cette partie puisque pour l'instant
on peut dire que le jeu des noirs
étaient quasi parfait le jeu des blancs
également puisque sa suite kasparov la
imprécisions d'intel et karpov qui rate
un peu sa chance mais on peut dire
encore une fois que dans cette position
enfin on va on va expliquer on va
expliquer d'abord mais on va dire que la
foi de café anatoli karpov et une faute
de vieux joueurs et de vieux joueurs
défensifs
c'est à dire que lorsque l'adversaire a
tendance à vous à vous prendre à la
gorge comme ça au lieu de deux
de riposter on a plutôt tendance à se
protéger donc là c'est ce que fait un
atelier dans cette position il continue
à se protéger alors que dans cette
position il est le temps de réagir un
peu d'accord donc d'après toi la bonne
solution quand on voit un chien enragé
qui nous sautent dessus c'est pas
d'essayer de se protéger c'est plutôt
d'aller le chercher
est ce que gary est un chien enragé on
peut se poser la question alors
explications techniques donc dans cette
question anatoli karpov retire son
cavalier sur la casa fuite
coût 1 précise il y avait mieux en fait
il fallait prendre l'option h4 voilà ce
pion était en prise
donc il fallait le prendre pourquoi on
dit qu'il a pris ça à l'air curieux
c'est que on se dit pourquoi la tour ne
viendra pas reprendre et bien à ce
moment là le fou g5 ne sera plus protégé
donc tu aurais four en fout ça c'est la
grande explication donc là il faut que
[ __ ] en cavalier maintenant fou prend
fou qu'est ce qui se passe on voit si on
après un simple compte deux pions
égalité matérielle mais on voit plus ou
sort et les compensations des blancs
dans cette position c'est à dire que si
les noirs
je vous reproche un pouf aux ossètes
s'ils ramènent leurs fous sur la case
hausse est comme ça ils auront une
position solide meilleur sur le tour
depuis en boivent tous les avantages là
il ya le clan des cinq reprises donc on
peut supposer que kasparov prennent ce
pion reprenne ses pions le bon coup
maintenant dans cette position c'est fou
aux 7
il faut forcer le food et 5 à partir de
cette colonne d autant que le feu prenne
le cavalier on reprend du pied et là
qu'est ce qu'on voit kasparov ne peut
plus faire le grand roque puisque la
dame des vitres contrôler la casse bien
donc ça c'est une règle de base du jeu
d'échecs
quand la case bien et contrôlé on ne
peut pas faire le grand roque est ici
problème quand même pour dire et
kasparov ou sous on pourrait être les
traces de son avantage on ne sait pas on
sait pas
c'est un mystère mais cette position
donc apprécier quelques coups simples
karpov aurait pu complètement annihilé
l'offensive de garry kasparov et
et au lieu de ça il permet à gary donc
de conserver l'initiative et on sait que
gary est d'autant plus dangereux que aux
échecs donc que lorsqu'il anémie native
et on va voir qu'après la suite est
carrément inévitable donc on va
recommencer cette suite qui est toute
simple
effectivement enfin simple attention
jean luc 1 c'est pas évident évident et
oui il ya peut-être une vérité cachée il
ya peut-être quelques solutions pour
améliorer le jeu blanc mais mais de
toute façon c'est la meilleure ligne
donc cavalier procureur car c'était ça
qu'il fallait jouer on force vous prend
cavaliers poupon les blancs maintenant
gagne l'option des cinq les noirs
rapatrie pourchassés sous cette pièce
qui attendaient 5 faucons cavaliers
pions prend et maintenant position à peu
près équilibré est ce qu'on peut
supposer
enfin est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
karpov n'ai pas vu qui avait pour cadre
on peut le supposer parce que dans ce
tournoi j'ai je suis pas très très
gentil avec anatolie mais j'ai été très
surpris par sa partie contre alexei
shirov ils étaient gagnants il était
complètement gagnant et il a loupé il a
loupé des coûts extrêmement évident et
j'ai l'impression qu'à nathalie
calcul - moins bien qu'auparavant
actuellement et je pense même que c'est
sont peut-être son principal défaut
parce que probablement il a une
compréhension qui n'a pas changé il
comprend toujours très très bien les
échecs mais malheureusement le calcul
est très important à ce jeu et il oublie
quelquefois des ventes très simple
peut-être qu'il a vu des fantômes dans
cette position il a vu des choses qui
n'existaient pas parce que on peut on a
du mal à imaginer qu'un ancien champion
du monde ne pas voir qu'il approche
catalan l'autre l'autre hypothèse qui
est possible jean-luc il s'est dit je
joue cavalier fuite
je suis mieux c'est bien je ne veux pas
faire mais je veux jouer cette position
mais il faut dire que voir des fantômes
aux échecs c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi
mal calculé on appelle ça c'est un
calcul donc inefficace et mal évalué les
positions c'est aussi un mauvais calcul
donc cavalier fuite le mauvais choix
le mauvais choix est tout à fait et la
galerie donc continuer à prendre
l'initiative par cavalier p5 donc là on
voit que ils essayent de rentrer sur la
case des six qui c'est une menace
directe qui est des 56 et chaque haut
rang ensuite on gagne en rupture avec
cette phase il manque
et puis et puis là karpov
on se demande vraiment comment il va
pouvoir tenir cette position c'est
puisque des coups comme damas cinq
échecs ne servent à rien puisqu'il ya c2
c3 et et qu' il n'a pas de coût de
développement alors quand même je vais
je vais arrêter jean-luc il y avait une
possibilité peut être intéressante
c'était qu'un damas cinq échecs
oui voilà supposons c2 c3 maintenant on
peut jouer sous pression ces cinq quand
même avec une position pas forcément
très clair avec une position pas
forcément très clair mais il ya quand
même b2b cat ya b2b 4 heureusement
d'ailleurs pour les blancs maintenant on
prendrait en d4
puis on prend becache en créant b4 bon
je suppose qu'on prend du fou c'est une
possibilité
le roi blanc bougerait en f1 et là il ya
une position quand même complexe et qui
vient d'arriver
les blancs une mauvaise structure de
pions ils ont une pièce pour trois pions
des noirs à ton avis cette pression
était
et simple complexe pour pour un amateur
peut-être mais pour un champion du monde
probablement pas surtout avec des pièces
avec la paire de foot braquer sur le roi
adverse et
et un roi en f1 finalement assez en
sécurité alors que le roi noir lui n'est
pas en sécurité
donc c'est effectivement net avantage
blanc dans cette position ce n'est pas
une option donc on peut pas se prémunir
contre eux que cavaler des six échecs
il n'y a pas de solution donc il faut
trouver une petite pièce de suite pour
le roi voilà c'est ce que fait anatoli
karpov si les objets plus ou moins joué
cavalier en dix-sept la bon alors là
garry kasparov aurait pu jouer qui est
d'essayer ça mais il a trouvé mieux oui
il a trouvé mieux puisque cahier dé 6,3
et fuites et les choses n'étaient
peut-être pas aussi simple mais mais il
a décidé d'ouvrir complètement le roi
qui qui est qui est en face de lui donc
par page 7h 5h si ce très joli coup bon
donc h 56 quelle est l'idée déjà sûr qu
on prend pions ça c'est la première
question qu'on peut se poser
donc l'idée je crois dans sa position
c'est de jouer cavalier des six échecs
donc voilà le roi qui avait fait forcée
voilà oui
et maintenant et l'agencé vialatte de
venir avec la dame / h 5
ça commence à faire peur tout ça pour
menacer et dames price est mat
voilà soutenu par le cavalier l'unique
défense serait de mettre un cavalier ans
le 5 peut-on voilà pas vu d'autres et on
peut dans la foule pour acheter tout ça
simplement je fou prend 1,6 et mater
leurs rangs quelques coups oui et tout à
fait il ya un math rapide ici tout à
fait effrayant ça va très très vite en
mai sur roy g8 qui possède le tour g1
peut-être aussi manger un week-end
prochain 7 c'est pas mal non plus avec
position un petit président est enfin là
c'est de la boucherie pourquoi parce que
le roi blanc est en totale sécurité
il ya trois pièces blanches autour du
roi noir et toutes les variantes vous le
diront dans cette position c'est un
match quasi forcée
donc les pièces blanches maintenant même
si elles sont en infériorité numérique
puisqu'il y en a il y en a pas tant que
ça tiens d'ailleurs dans cette position
après cavaillé pointe 7 il ya une jolie
variantes
whiteduck justice madame 8 défense
des noirs de fougue 4 x 4 l'idc tour g1
l'idée c'est de jouer tour g1 mais quand
et pas de défense il faut 4 donc pour
contrôler la case h7 où le roi pouvait
éventuellement fuir sûr d'un point cet
accord donc oui oui les ventes en fait
coule de source
maintenant c'est à dire qu'on a vraiment
une position qui qui se prête à des
belles complications et une bonne
gestion des complications un bel
exercice tactique donc anatoli karpov
sur l'a6 ne proposant 1,6 à cause de
cette fuite forcée qui avaient des six
échecs et damages 5
il trouve une autre solution anatoli
karpov il joue cavalier prend pioncer 5
pourquoi pas faut être quatre il nous
surprend à chaque coup ils rient
kasparov s'est chaque coup et d'une
puissance incroyable et on s'y attend
pas oui dans cette position il décide
donc
de toujours de donner du jeu à ce
cavalier b5 donc hélas il lui laisse la
possibilité de venir sur la case la case
c7 qui provoquera donc une fourchette et
en même temps ils se gardent toujours la
possibilité à n'importe quel moment de
prendre le pion g7 tout à fait donc là
c'est une menace c'est un poids
intermédiaire en fait on peut qualifier
ça comme ça exactement c'est un coût qui
crée une autre menace donc on va revenir
à la position précédente c'était
celle-là
garry kasparov aurait pu prendre angers7
mais il préfère jouer un coup d'abord un
peu différent fois aux cartes avec
l'idée qui a laissé cette fourchette et
gardant l'autre menace qui est champion
roy fuite
à noter ricard peuvent fait d'une pierre
deux coups il part à priori les deux
menaces
oui il parlait de menaces mais le roi
est toujours toujours à poil ouais
toujours à poil je peux dire qu'après h
congé cet essai la partie roi prend
forcé et voilà et donc le roi en g7 n'a
pas d'abri
il est en péril donc garé en profite
pour faire le grand roque et année sa
dernière tour sur le roi noir et c'est
hier que la tour déjà pour l'instant
mais sur la colonne des sur la dame mais
il peut jouer éventuellement quand il
veut oui tout ranger un pour mettre la
pression sur les rois d'un jour de
position si on veut établir une défense
sérieuse
il faut qu'on trouve un endroit où le
roi noir ne pourra pas être en échec
donc ça c'est pas si facile
ouais donc ce que fait anatolie c'est le
coup force et on va dire ouais ouais
huit auraient fui de toute façon le roi
noir devait aller sur une case il est
allé sur la casa fuite en avant ce qu'on
peut dire ça kasparov là il fait un coup
un peu vis la wii juwi dans sa position
je pense qu'il joue ce coup de
simplement pour montrer à anatolie que
toutes ces pièces sont très bien placés
et il n'a pas besoin de se presser pour
pour pour terminer la partie alors on va
montrer le coup c'est roy b1 dans une
belle position d' attaque alors que les
pièces blanches donc il ya encore la
tourache 1 qui demandent peut-être être
développées le fou j'ai 2 dont on a
peut-être envie d essayer de l'améliorer
non car un kasparov y joue roi c'est un
b 1
un cookie mais le roi a effectivement un
peu plus en sécurité puisque plus
derrière les pions mais qui ne menace
rien déjà d'une part qui ne fait rien
est ce qu'on peut dire à ce moment là
que garry kasparov pense qu'il est
gagnant oui oui oui
gary est sûr qu'il va gagner sûr qu'il
va gagner en jouant le cours à b1
il explique et anatoli karpov que quoi
qu'il arrive lui donc avec les noirs
anatoli karpov sur lui donne du temps il
ne peut rien en faire c'est à dire qu'il
peut il pourra pas même en jouant deux
trois coups de suite amélioré la
position de son roi alors que garry
kasparov lui sur mille hommes de trois
coups et bien il n'aura plus qu'à aller
le chercher
et d'ailleurs ce qui est marrant dans
cette position c'est qu'à nathalie donc
ne développe pas une pièce
donc finalement ils acceptent
l'acceptent qui provoque même les
événements dans cette position il
accepte la défaite
anatoly karpov il accepte lui dans cette
position garry kasparov qui les
proposent de perdre il accepte mais
parce qu'il n'a pas le choix il n'a pas
chaussé la dure réalité du jeu d'échecs
dans certaines positions alors qu'est ce
qui te fait dire qu'il est qu'ils
acceptent de perdre ici même s'il a joué
le coup qu'il a joué à 7 à 6 noeuds ne
développe aucune pièce donc évidemment
et les blancs vont devoir placer leurs
cavaliers sur une case un peu périlleuse
donc donc garry kasparov va de l'avant
on n'a pas besoin de le redire il ya
évidemment sur la case c7 et je pense
pas qu'il envisageait d'autres coups
d'ailleurs non pas du tout le cavalier
donc il est quelque peu enfermé mais
immédiat ries avait prévu quelque chose
ce dernier a tout vu évidemment donc
tour s'est vite gagne le cavalier c'est
à dire qu'on menace de jouer tout
reprend cavaliers et quand le fou vient
reprendre ont fait d'un profond on a
pris un fouet un cavalier contre une
tour c'est à dire que ça serait bon pour
un hôtel karpov
ce serait très très bon mais
malheureusement malheureusement garrier
revue plus loin alors là là c'est le
festival qui commence un petit peu le
feu d'artifice pas exactement le foot
fonction des cinq boom alors qu'est ce
qui se passe là oif ce que vraiment
c'est quand même un coût qui arrive un
peu de nulle part et vient donc garé
profite donc donc de la colonne des
ouverte entre la tour et la dame
donc ils profitent donc de cette colonne
ouverte donc ils sacrifient une pièce
pour ouvrir cette colonne et et
et puis la dame puisque la dame n'a plus
de 15 dans une position la date
d'application également que la pointe de
la variante c'est que la dame noire donc
a priori la dame est une pièce qu'on
enferme rarement ça peut arriver c'est
parce que c'est joli on aime bien montre
toujours quand on est enfermé là mais
c'est très dur parce que c'est d'un
doute et la pièce la plus puissante
c'est celle qui peut aller sur le plus
de cases qui est donc le plus de
possibilité de s'échapper on a du mal à
l'enfermer et là c'est ce qui est
pourtant en train de se passer et après
[ __ ] en d5
sur un coup tout simple comme tout
repenser cette galerie pourrait dans
cette position de jouer tout simplement
fou prend cavaliers ces six fours
encaissé six attaques la dame avec la
tour donc il récupère sa pièce à un
tacle à tôt avec le fond il va gagner du
matériel donc là ses gains matériels et
la tap continue c'est pas je prends le
matériel et c'est fini c'est jeu pour le
matériel et le roi noir de la télé car
peu fait toujours en danger
donc ici après faut prendre d'essai avec
la norvège réplique d'anatolie karpov et
quasi forcée
j'en prends fou tour pampillon la la
dame est enfermé et lazaoui la dame est
enfermé et sur cavaliers avec aidé c'est
sûr qu'à valider cette je pense que gary
peut tout simplement doublé ses tours
non ici un coup très fort jean dame 17
d'amsterdam des deux dames des deux qui
fait d'une pierre deux coups puisque sa
menace de jouer tout reprend qu'avait
gagnant donc la dame et sa menace
fasciste et en même temps faut aussi se
mate et surtout prend cavaliers ans et 7
évidemment le four ou prendre c'est
cette voie là l'an dernier en défaut
pour un tour la dame prend et on prend
le cavaliere 17la énorme initiative donc
qu'il va continuer deux pions et une
tour contre x et cavaliers bref aucune
chance pour un atelier karpov de s'en
sortir
oui aucune chance tu n'as pas l'air
convaincu jean luc et 1 6 2 c'est quand
même une position pas très engageant
d'oncle anatoli karpov plutôt que de
rentrer dans cette suite se dit bas
quitte à perdre la dame autant la
simplifier oui il fait un sacrifice qui
dans certaines positions peut être
intéressant mais là il ya deux pions -
oui la leur ces dames prend cavaliers
ses sept fous prend et tout reprend donc
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on voit il la
donne la dame pour trois pièces mineurs
voilà les pièces mineurs étant les
cavaliers les fonds qu'il a deux
cavaliers un fou contre une dame mais
effectivement comme tu l'as dit il ya
d'option avec la dame dont tokyo contre
trois petites pièces et le roi de karpov
toujours dans le vent puis c'est pas les
meilleures pièces s'il karpov avait deux
fous dans cette position un fonds us est
un fonds de six ce serait beaucoup mieux
enfin on peut pas changer ma position
malheureusement ça
on ne peut pas changer donc ici c'est un
gain technique pour garry kasparov très
probablement anatoli karpov a pas
forcément la volonté de défendre ça
parce que c'est assez insupportable je
pense le show et kasparov
avec cette poubelle c'est très dur
d'avoir cette position en 24 coup on
attend mais on n'a même pas envie de la
jouer
ouais on n'a même pas envie de jouer et
pourquoi pas ce qu'on voit qu'il ya
toutes les pièces emprise la tour c'est
certes elle n'est pas défendu donc elle
peut être attaquer n'importe quel moment
le quai et c5
aussi il ya un peu il n'est pas stable
le fou à cette non plus la tourache 8
n'est pas stable non plus donc toutes
les pièces noires donc d'anatolie car
peuvent peuvent être attaquées donc ça
devient un vrai cauchemar à défendre
cette position puisque il ya tout un
prix simplement ces treize attaques
double vont pleuvoir les fourchettes les
échecs
bref l'horreur donc karpov et quand même
un combattant donc il s'est un peu
débattu tour f5
c'est ça le foot kasparov tour 17 ces
trois vidéos reid kasparov il nourrit il
prend son temps il a pas besoin d'eux il
y avait carpeaux qu'espère fabula
fourchette
oui parce que dans cette position car
postes menacés quand même malgré sa
position catastrophique il mène à six
cavaliers c6 des 4 way mais c'était pas
vraiment une manager les cuisses y avait
toujours le ku'damm 5 ha oui et oui
c'est horrible il ya tellement pias
emprise côté noir qu' on ne peut plus
faire de menaces
oui donc sa c3 c3 c'est de la précaution
peut-être qu'ils veulent couper de b4
pour déstabiliser ce cavalier mais je
crois pas je crois qu'en fait ces trois
c'est juste vraiment pour dire à karpov
dans cette position je joue c'est 3
pourquoi je me mets d'options comme ça
comme ça t'en fous ne pourra plus jamais
m'ennuyer jeu nous prémunit contre toute
action de ce fou de cases noires et
voilà je suis totalement décontracté
dans cette position m6 tongiens je
remets une petite aux enjeux on sent que
ça va arriver là ça arrivent de tous les
côtés d'alger cat et puis d'alger cette
possible et des mythes dame g4 il arrive
roi en 1 8
et là je crois que c'est la petite
combinaison finale
tout de suite pas tout de suite tour h5
tout 28 tours f8 et maintenant la petite
commune il est maintenant la petite
combine au final donc regardez bien
cette position
il reste donc trois co 2 coups de coups
qui ont été jouées les blancs jouent et
gagnent alors jean-luc ce genre de
petits trucs
toi tu les vois tout de suite oui je
je peux avouer que ce genre de coup
droit doit être trouvée rapidement
donc dans cette position dont il faut
trouver une petite combinaison qui
permet de faire une fourchette et qui
permet de gagner un petit peu de
matériel donc on va on va montrer la
solution la solution tout reprend
cavaliers et on prend ces 5 voilà donc
là effectivement si on ne reprend pas la
tour c'est pas la peine de continuer le
combat puisque on a plus que deux pièces
un fou un cavalier contre une dame c'est
trop peu fou prend tout en est
maintenant
zuroff échec voilà fourchette entre le
roi a eu 8 et le fou 6,5
donc là le seul coup pour un atelier
karpov enfin un des coups possibles
puisque là plus question de seul coup et
part donc cavalier à vii boom d'un
profond là maintenant on refait le
compte du matériel en voix qui a dames
contre tours et cavaliers en fin d'année
d'options contre tours et cavani est
toujours le roi d'un halo et karpov dans
le vent ou toujours de l'attak louis
attaque donc ici c'est terminé et après
damage cinq échecs anatoli karpov
abandonne donc sa position était
passablement pas tenable oui c'était
fini je pense que j'ai eu envie de
continuer plus longtemps le calvaire
c'est vrai que ça doit pas être facile
contre surtout contre l'autre en plus on
le connaît garry kasparov et c'est un
fan de mimiques en tout genre et quand
il est gagnant il envie tout le monde le
sache où et puis bon
la manière à quel ce qu'on dit gary en
ce moment j'imagine que pendant la
partie il a dû faire les cent pas il a
dû arriver un petit peu en retard il a
dû faire un petit peu ses pitreries
habituel et donc je pense qu'un atelier
avait envie d'arrêter
il avait envie de rentrer faire une
petite sieste anatoli karpov donc
mauvaise partie pour karpov donc
l'analyse de partie s'est terminée jean
luc ici tu devais résumer cette partie
partie modèle partie d'attac une partie
intéressante par cette idéologie est
partie intéressante puisque la carro
kahn qui revenait à l'actualité
a été a été sérieusement démonter par
par gary est ce qu'on peut penser que
kasparov a trop et ça depuis très
longtemps cette variante d'avancé avec
cette variante mais qui la gardait pour
une grande occasion
je crois que je ne sais pas si gary a
choisi forcément une vente
exceptionnelle je pense qu' il a joué de
position qu'il connaissait très bien et
qu'il qu'il a adapté comme on a pu
l'expliquer tout à l'heure à la
psychologie de karpov
il a joué une position où il a voulu
comme on a dit étranglé karpov d'aider
directement il a transmis le serpent
voilà et
karpov
c'est très mal débattu pendant cette
position il s'est laissé faire et voilà
la punition pas facile donc alors les
résultats du tournoi on les a déjà
mentionné en début d'émission
il ya un affrontement sympathique qui
arrive jean luc tu va peut-être pouvoir
nous donner les pronostics puisque c'est
devenu traditionnel ici on a eu les
pronostics de laurent frayssinet les
pronostics de nicolas laval et dans les
deux dernières éditions
là il ya une partie judit polgar avec
les blancs contre anne garry kasparov
ce sera la septième entre de linares les
deux leaders se rencontrent je pense que
je moi je pronostique un match nul donc
ça c'est optimiste pour j'ai dit oh pour
gary judith à l'eiblen donc
je pense qu'elle est elle est très très
en forme est que si si elle décide de ne
pas prendre trop de risques il ya peu de
chances qu'elle perde cette partie oui
donc analyse nul personnellement je
pense que c'est
kasparov qui va gagner même avec les
noirs enfin bon ça c'est une théorie
alors maintenant résultat final de ce
tournoi bon résultat de finale de ce
tournoi c'est gary qui va gagner
c'est gary qui va gagner bon alors là
maintenant que gary est à + 3 ça paraît
hautement probable effectivement mais
est-ce qu'il va accroître son avance ou
pas or il peut il peut essayer
d'augmenter d'arriver à +5
je pense qu'il peut arriver à plus 5 ans
avec un peu de chance +5 c'est énorme
c'est une score énorme c'est sa saisie
sur dix c'est énorme mais quand on voit
des partis comme ça
adoptez qu'il a fait + 3 dans la
première année il a fait plus trop en
sept parties ça veut dire qu'ils
finiraient par trois sur quatre
oui vous pourrez terminer par deux
matches nuls et deux victoires c'est
c'est très probable donc garry kasparov
avec +5 donc là c'est un pronostic
sérieux tu t'avances beaucoup deuxième
du tournoi alors j'ai dit ou pas judith
parce qu'elle va se faire manger par les
requins de retour c'est à dire
évidemment penser avec sigh shirov les
picards l'écho qui sont comme les deux
meilleurs tours prennent kasparov
oui je pense que judith à une tâche
difficile donc c'est de bien terminer
dans son - elle a bien commencé et à mon
avis
et
alexei shirov peu la rattraper
évidemment je pense qu'un excellent
shirov peut les rattraper
bon on va dire que comme j'aime bien je
lui dit on va dire que j'espère qu'elle
va terminer deuxième de ce tournoi ce
qui serait vraiment remarquable et au
gré de chaud comment est-ce que tu le
sens dans ce tournoi dernier détaché ou
ou peut-être qu'il peut revenir
tu parles du joueur qui qui al'âge de du
titre perdu voilà donc ben j'espère
qu'il va rester à moins 2 jusqu'à la fin
du tournoi
ça ce serait très bien pour une première
participation dans un tournoi de ce
cette envergure et pour un joueur qui a
énormément de talent un jeune joueur qui
a beaucoup beaucoup de talent donc est
ce qu'un coup de coeur quelque chose que
tu souhaiterais au niveau du résultat
final par exemple jeudi guérir le
tournoi ou
garry kasparov personnes parties de
suite je ne sais pas le coup de coeur on
va dire que oui bon oui j'aimerais bien
que judith inquiète garric gary un
accident et que les capitaux rico aussi
art est un petit peu cette série de
matches nuls et tous qu'il avait entamée
sitôt mois auparavant
qu'ils continuent dans la série g
revient peter l'écho gagne une partie et
échangent un petit peu petit peu et
fassent quelque chose un peu plus
tonique parce que parce que bon c'est un
joueur aussi solide si fort qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à gagner c'est quand même
curieux
jean-luc merci de tes commentaires sur
linares on va passer maintenant un autre
sujet d'actualité
il s'agit du tournoi de cappelle la
grande
le fameux plus fort open de france et
peut-être même du monde alors on va
rappeler quelques statistiques 700
joueurs 418 joueurs internationaux 93
grand maître 72 m 24 mètres filet très
beau palmarès et après huit rondes donc
puisque pour l'instant il ya bien rondes
qui ont été joués la dernière sera jouée
samedi demain un seul joueur en tête
avec sept points sur huit
il s'agit de gazelle je ne connais pas
benghazi et je ne connais pas goesel
c'est un fait curieux quand même pour le
plus fort au maniement mais c'est très
fort quand même donc gazelles en tête
avec sept points donc on salue sa
performance il a que 2480 points elo et
deuxièmes ex-aequo nous avons notre star
donc de dax laurent frayssinet je
croyais en lui que tu le connais bien
puisque vous habiter ensemble on est que
locataire
donc oui laurent frayssinet qui
qui a énormément de talent et qu'il a la
meilleure performance du tournoi
il faut signaler donc qui fait un taux
remarquable est qui et qui demain donc
va essayer essayer d'accrocher un podium
pour ce tournoi et peut-être de gagner
le tournoi
alors il est en super forme il a pour
l'instant une perf à plus de 2750 points
elo donc c'est une perf tout à fait
respectable puisque ça lui dans la
classe pendre et tous meilleurs joueurs
du monde
rappelons qu'il n'a que 19 ans quand
même tout petit tout petit tout sympa il
a il c'est une des plus belles réussites
de sa carrière oui c'est une des plus
belles réussites de sa carrière et on
peut dire que bon ce tournoi qui est un
très fort tournoi mais qui est surtout
un tournoi de préparation on peut dire
que dans cette optique c'est de très bon
augure avant le avant le grand prix de
bordeaux et avant le tournoi de denguin
d'enghien et qui sont et qui seront les
prochains rendez vous de laurent
frayssinet le grand prix de bordeaux on
va en parler très vite donc autres
joueurs français ya jean-marc degraeve
qui lui pour l'instant à six points sur
huit donc pas terrible arnaud hauchard
cinq points sur huit donc mauvaise
mauvais résultats c'est très dur pour
les français dans ce tournoi mais c'est
vrai que 93 de remettre ça fait des
grands maîtres français dans des
mauvaises places c'est tout à fait
normal donc appel fin demain on vous
dira évidemment qui a gagné ce
fantastique tournoi fantastique open
dans la prochaine mission de petits
sujets encore jean-luc ya des élections
donc les fameuses élections
présidentielles de mars
et que son présidentielle de la
fédération française d'échecs on
rappelle qu'elle préside en place qui
est jean-claude loubatières il y a en
face de lui d'autres candidats notamment
jean-claude ampleur larbitre capelle la
demande un avis ben je crois que je ne
fais pas de politique mais non je ne
sais pas je on va dire que le meilleur
gagne
quel meilleur gagne donc les élections
auront lieu à l'hôtel le parnasse si
vous êtes licencié vous pouvez y aller à
partir de 10 heures
ça sera dimanche matin donc dimanche 4
ou 5 le 5 avril et donc nous terminons
cette émission en vous annonçant le
grand prix de bordeaux grand prix de
bordeaux qui traditionnellement a lieu
le 6 et 7 avril de chaque année
c'est la cinquième édition le palmarès
des années précédentes
donc j'en crois qu'elle est suivie
l'année dernière puisque tu étais
commentateurs de ce grand prix de
bordeaux donc l'année dernière
évidemment c'était l'anglais michael
adams qui avait
et qui avait gagné brillamment le le
tournoi le grand prix de bordeaux et qui
avait été très impressionnant et alors
on va rappeler est donc grand prix de
bordeaux c'est à bordeaux c'est dans un
théâtre le théâtre fémina il ya quatre
joueurs
cette année on va vous annoncer les
joueurs c'est en direct sur diagonale
donc vous pouvez revoir par exemple les
différer de l'année dernière en allant
sur diagonale événement en cliquant donc
en haut à droite de la petite fenêtre
qui est à côté de la télé diagonale
événement vous cliquez sur grand prix de
bordeaux vous avez les différé qui sont
archivés vous pouvez revoir et cette
année donc ça sera 6 et 7 avril au
théâtre fémina avec loïc van well i donc
numéro 12 mondiale qui donc est très
bien préparée dans les ouvertures qui
est assez fort en partie rapide
inky à 2700 aussi qui a plus de 2700 le
meilleur joueur hollandais donc numéro
deux mondial et trois jeunes aux dents
longues qu'on a mis avec eux pour enfin
avec lui pour essayer de le battre
c'est le challenge il y à laurent
frayssinet donc le local de l'épreuve
puisqu'il est de date
on l'a déjà dit dans cette émission et
qui très en forme très en forme
igor nataf il y en a quatre qui qui a
battu shirov ou derniers championnats du
monde
peut-être pas shirov quand même puisque
shirov a été en finale
charles trenet il a battu short qui
était un peu short à dire exactement
donc il avait reçu le short en pas mal
de parties rapides
rappelons bordeaux 7 ans mais rapide et
igor joue pas mal a priori les parties
semi rapides également oui puisqu'il
était très brillant aussi où thomas
d'aubervilliers il ya quelques temps et
donc aussi je crois qu'il y à un joueur
espagnol valero
valero qui est champion du monde des
moins de 18 ans donc c'est un jeune
effectivement il a presque 2600 aussi
donc trois jeunes 1
top top c'est loïc houdré lit donc qui
va réussir à le battre alors jean-luc
eux pour qui pour qu'ils étudient dans
ce grand prix de bordeaux et en russie
qu on va dire que mon petit favori c
c'est laurent laurent frayssinet leur
offre à signer est le favori mais
il va falloir qu'il travaille ça va pas
être facile en tout cas on compte sur
toi pour le pour le préparer pour ce
grand prix de bordeaux donc l'actualité
s'est terminée donc on rappelle compris
de bordeaux 6 7 avril on en reparlera
bien entendu jean luc merci d'avoir
suivi cette émission merci loi et donc
eh bien en attendant de poursuivre on
vous dit à la semaine prochaine vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau diagonale
spécial linares merci